welcome to this video playing lasso
lockers all from Iceland Iceland and
Norway I have yeah yeah okay
this is obviously Norway but sort of
brain slipping him okay what can I do
baby
later the clothes grew as I usually do
but not the line I used to claim this
somewhat passive children I haven't
really looked at an alternative yet it's
okay it's let's do the side self I mean
not that I know the opening but let's
let's do it anyway this is maybe the
sharpest line that black has well not
now not now okie-dokie is just ghost III
which is of course always possible I'm
going to do this typically regrouping
this is kind of the trademark slide safe
maneuver yeah I was wondering if how am
I playing this now I really like to get
the C point involved I'm kind of used to
that from the children so I wonder I can
go back maybe maybe like in the Bray I
could go back instead of putting it on a
five yah Knight f5 is an idea I was
thinking I can probably just go do this
but and maybe Knight h4 is an annoying
reply to that I guess it is
but maybe I can start with this yeah
this has 95 as an additional idea so
oops this I didn't think about it all to
deform that's it's also bit uncommon but
probably not bad hmm yeah but she's not
threatening anything right I can't
actually do this I was thinking that he
should somehow care about the a4 corn
like yeah I mean he cannot allow me to
take the bishop this is completely
giving up any hopes of an advantage so
he has to basically move it here and
then I can I could think about taking a
4 which is a bit it's not great for my
pawn structure but good for my for my
bishop payer let's say I have the pair
of bishops now and I cannot resist
getting those if if he lets me
okey-dokey I will take him and now let's
see i've got the two bishops which is
good and he's got this slightly curious
pawn here hmm
I could go Quinn c8 if I like let's go
Quinn c8 and see that he I mean he has
to do something with the pawn yeah how
to play this no Bishop e7 and tending
Queen g4 moves like that I have no
problem here anyway but it's a question
how to really get something like like an
advantage going it's not like I'm
playing for equality with the two
bishops for no compensation and we came
I don't know I'm thinking of King g7
like g6 King g7 does this could could be
an idea
yeah Queen B 3 it's a bit bit through a
problem has be sadness hanging look at
fate it's not a move I like to play but
ok Queen b3 I play rook b8 next move
threatening a bishop bishop discovery
says to move the Queen again and then
then then go in Queen g-form activating
the Queen I can do this at least one
away I wish apace happiness is not just
a possible anyway ridiculously I can
just take g5 then ok Queen g4 now right
just attacking is annoyed asking him
what he intends to do with the piece are
there any technical tricks no where 3 is
just weakening right and I'll just go
back why is he going to play King F to
engage one for some age file business
yeah he's trying to do that no not that
I believe it in particular but he's
trying to do that mmm like to play d5
good
hmm yeah it's not that great yeah the H
file is a factor and I really wonder why
I'm so slow I'm even slower than usual
which is not easy to do I mean I'm
always not especially quick but this is
really slow I mean the position is good
but the clock is not not good that much
okay so I thought I could probably take
here maybe not good good okay yeah and
this is No why am I thinking this is a
check this is kind of weird of course I
have to take on f/8 first I forgot to
insert Roop take surveyed wow this is
really ridiculous I look down and 2
minutes 20 this is the kind of game
where you really can say I completely
lost it on my own yeah giving it giving
it away completely yeah that's not much
to do here something like can I go g5 at
some moment it's not helping much
ah yeah I can also resign here but I
sort of I was still thinking that I
maybe have some some tricks but candy
not can just do this and I have six eggs
come on let's resign that where is it
what it was really really idiotic I mean
I was at the time the time management
was of course outlandish but but still
and I'm not not surprised that I had
some really good opportunities here
Queens III was already winning I'm not
seeing why yet but this is the comp
evaluation what am I doing here
a bishop C aid I'm taking this okay yeah
this is this is really winning him okay
yeah well can't they just it dead and
here I'm also of course fine but I
totally totally forgot and that hit that
I have to take on evade first the comp
wants to do this with a pretty clear
advantage but 0.8 this is an idea here
that that that stop fish is giving and
taking this with a check and the
position is simply opening up quickly
and I have two bishops Val yes no good
coordination and this is probably okay
but not great in comparison yeah of
course yeah I just have to recapture I
was somehow thinking I can take first
which is just the hallucination I have
to do this check and I was this was kind
of the situation that I imagined that I
get like two pawns and maybe play
against his King with with the bishops
on an open board but I was not thinking
clearly
and hinted this which is just ridiculous
what a weird we had the way to play and
I as really spent hot too much time
around T it was okay but what exactly
did cost me so much time this was okay
TX takes
I took a while for that movie cannot
take that lot that much time maybe hear
it sit still okay I mean but in terms of
time the position as mentioned is
winning anyway with Queen G 3 when f3
was also not not really good I mean I
thought you had to retreat but then I'd
also just go back and I just have the
two bishops in this position probably
giving me at least a slight edge
he has play against the a pawn but I
kind of like the bishops still computer
gives it is equal 0.14 white okay yeah
but if your blunder who rook it's not a
good idea okay well thanks for watching